[Applause]
i hope this is good
happy thursday everyone i know i look
great
those injections of panda tears into my
face are really paying off
we made them cry by reading aloud from
kilmeade's book
the only side effect is me craving
bamboo shoots 24 hours a day
all right enough of that crap
so
we're learning more about the july 4th
fiend
now i ain't showing the guy
but we have a replacement for him
this
this is a pile of horse
and trust me it's an improvement
we're not saying his name but that's not
good enough from now on it's just
from us
my apologies to the horses and their
thank you
fact is for every minute this fiend's
face is up on a screen you create more
just like it that's the power of the
media ask any woman who had a jennifer
aniston haircut in the 90s
or me
so enough with the guy's face he's a
mass killer not l'oreal's first
plus-sized cover girl
now mass shootings are almost always
linked to previous ones for the unstable
and evil they keep stats and record the
damage like ghouls in a demented fantasy
league so it infuriates me to see the
news slap that tattooed face right up
there all the time as they repeat the
same bs we already heard before
meanwhile the victims get a quick
mention like they had a tiny part in a
hollywood blockbuster
doesn't it drive you crazy
it does to me
because is it news or is it spectacle
and are we culpable when we know we're
supplying the fiend's reward which is
attention people don't commit suicide
for notoriety but suicide plus when you
take people with you that's for infamy
and we indulge it under the guise of
news as another monster gets 15 minutes
of fame
now i get it i'm in the news business
hard to believe
how did i get here
i don't belong here but now it's just
overkill now we know the guy had more
red flags than a parade on chinese new
year
threatening to kill his family i know i
know i'll cut him some slack on that one
i think we've all done that at least on
one thanksgiving
he threatened to kill himself he posted
stuff about mass shootings like it was
excerpts from an upcoming book he
painted a mural about killing he brought
up mass shooting the night before this
guy tipped his hand more times than me
at happy hour with a bottle of tito's
and did i even mention the face tats now
that doesn't mean you're a psycho killer
but i wouldn't ask him to babysit and
yet he got guns and he took innocent
lives so if you can't prevent that guy
with all those signs then what can you
do
makes no sense well you ever notice how
certain people only intervene in stuff
when the risk is low
but when there comes a time when someone
really has to speak up they don't you
know we used to hear neighbors say hmm
he was so quiet the last guy you'd
suspect but now they say oh yeah we all
knew that guy was a psycho oh well back
to watching tick tock videos
it's like if courage was coffee we've
replaced it with instant folgers
crystals it's the virtual version based
on virtue signaling and virtually
useless in the real world don't you dare
dead name a trans celebrity that'll get
you an instant ban
but racist murder fantasies from the
waukesha killer or video rants from new
york subway attacker zuckerberg and
company looked the other way you know we
condemn people for opinions but obvious
threats slide on by
because we aren't supposed to say
anything that's because deliberate
anti-social behavior is now just another
lifestyle choice and to call it out well
that makes you antisocial so now we sit
back and we watch
or we just film it
take a look at this scene in downtown
nyc three women destroy a restaurant all
because they were charged extra for
sauce
i haven't seen that violent reaction
since brian stelter was shorter to
mcnugget in his happy meal
but you could look at those bystanders
many of them so-called men cheering it
on while the workers cowered in the back
you know i'd ask them to man up but that
would be asking for toxic masculinity or
misgendering that's the kind of argument
intellectuals want to have while a
street loony bashes your head against
the sidewalk
so you got to ask yourself why would
anyone open a business
to see it smashed by a bunch of laughing
jerks why would any employee risk their
life for this
but we're now a nation of spectators so
quick to condemn pointless stuff but shy
away from the severely wrong there used
to be a name to describe people who saw
the risk of stepping in but went ahead
anyway
they were called brave
or crazy
this place used to be the home of the
brave but it's turning into a hen house
home of the chicken
we need help
from each other
now i'm not saying the mass shooting
could have been prevented but in an
engaged community who knows
now there's no law against minding your
own business in fact most of us like it
that way i don't need my neighbors
calling the cops on me every time they
see me doing tai chi on my balcony
wearing nothing but cat's old hair
extensions
but this isn't about laws it's about
community and we have lost community
looking out for your neighbor that
regular contact with them knowing the
police the businesses around you the
kids we should bring that back but it's
hard when politicians and teachers and
celebs pit us against each other like a
nation of drunken real housewives while
insisting your neighbors an oppressor
and your country's shared history is a
lie
perhaps the answer is less gawking and
more talking more time outside being a
neighbor as opposed to online
now i'm not saying you got to raise a
barn together like a mob of lemonade
guzzling amish
but maybe keep an eye out for each other
you know i hate to say this i can't
believe i'm saying this
but maybe this lady had a point
i know
hear me out
it was like 20 years ago okay her last
great point when she said it takes a
village to raise a child
because right now families they're
having a hard time and yeah i cannot
believe i just complimented hillary
clinton
truly pigs have flown
i think i see her husband doing a barrel
roll
[Applause]
he may look like a million bucks
but he's just won co-host of the clay
traverse at buck sexton showbox
he's so smart you can call him a noah at
all
author of the new book the rise of the
new puritans fighting back against
progressives war on fun
noah rothman see what i did there
she's like a fish stick white flaky and
smells up the whole room when microwaved
oh okay
that's strange fox news contributor cat
tim
and they traced all of the major
earthquakes to him playing hopscotch
my massive sidekick in the nwa world
television champion tyrus
[ __ ] how you doing there good sir thank
you for having me back my pleasure
wasn't my choice but okay i'll take it
i'll tell you um
you know i did i did an uh a monologue
kind of on this topic but i don't have
any solutions is there anything in there
that sounds like one other than just
getting to know the people around you or
something i don't know well you know i
see the the restaurant trashing
situation and there are so many of these
incidents now that are going viral where
people just seem to completely lose
their minds about something a lot of it
was on the airplanes for example over
masks and i think we have this
conversation about mental health mental
illness um and and it's time we finally
look at the fact that the pandemic
restrictions and this might sound crazy
i think it pushed a lot i'm not saying
it pushed people to be shooters but i
think it pushed a lot of people to just
view their fellow human beings
differently i think the lockdowns the
masking the constant fear porn from the
media and cnn and everything i think
that while we had a health pandemic from
the virus we've also been going through
a bit of a mental health pandemic that
no one's really been willing to talk
about at a national level because they
didn't need to do this they didn't need
to put us through all this as we've all
seen and so that's why the number of
fights on airplanes has gone up you know
3 000 or whatever it was now it's come
down because we don't have the pandemic
restriction of masks anymore i think you
see this all across society in different
ways playing out as for the mass shooter
situation you're trying to prevent what
is still statistically a very rare event
people talk about the rise in mass
shootings and i say yeah there's been a
rise do you know what the rise is and
they always say no and it's maybe from
12 to 15 yeah from 15 to 20. there are
330 million people in america right so
if you can't stop this guy with the face
tattoos by the way who was like a
walking billboard for crazy who are you
going to stop that's my point it's like
it's incredible and i know that his dad
helped him get that gun and if that's
turns out to be true his dad should be
accessory to murder if he if he helped
him do that no congrats on the new book
here it is i encourage everybody to read
this a fine writer
a fine writer and i don't mean that in a
physical sense so don't go to hr
um
i'll take the compliment okay there you
go uh what about you what do you mean
what do you think there's any like i i
kind of agree with buck that when you're
so close to zero
on a certain kind of incident it's
almost impossible to get it to zero so
it's like you you know you're going to
go between 15 and 30 for 10 years of
these incidents i don't know it is but
they're so disruptive to the social
fabric nationally that it does have a
different character to it buck's right
during the pandemic we had sort of a
mini civilizational breakdown and we
haven't really reckoned with that yet
there does need to be a reckoning at the
risk of getting thrown off this set
right now i still don't believe that it
takes a community
it takes a family see i don't know but
the thing is i don't know how you could
say it takes a family to raise a child
when you can't just create the family
you can't just create the parents if the
parents aren't there that's it yeah
intact families yeah and a family
structure that in a social structure
that rewards that as you say this father
sort of lived under a delusion if these
reports are correct we should add this
is alleged if these reports are correct
this father was sort of off offloading
his responsibility to the state to the
community to these institutions that
can't do what an engaged parent does
which is spot these red flags and
intervene when there's time an
institution can't do that in fact we've
been giving the state too much control
courts cps programs too much influence
over the family and parents and families
need to be intact and whole and engaged
yeah i i think that maybe it's not it's
the society itself has become so broken
apart that that it's like
this stuff
it takes a village meaning that the
people in a village will notice that if
their next-door neighbor's kid is acting
squirrely but you don't have that
anymore and no one's going to tell you
that your kid's acting squirrely because
then you could get in trouble yeah but
but also you can intervene with these
parents who are otherwise disengaged
from their child yeah and perhaps coax
them into being a parent yeah i don't
think you can tyrus i don't think you
can coax if you're a bad parent you're a
bad this is why i don't have kids
yeah
the little firework thing the other
night kind of cemented that
you know gutfeld you did make
besides the fact your monologues are
always spot-on but you did i don't know
if you did it on purpose or accident
you you complimented hillary clinton and
that's a start yeah i'll tell you you're
awe but that's the problem
that's the problem we're so busy
fighting
over the wrong
that we're not paying attention to the
bad stuff so we do need the solution is
unfortunately we need the karen's and we
need the woke and we need the trolls
they just got to change their directive
instead of going after rich successful
mostly white men
on twitter and start going after the
weird tweets start looking for the weird
behaviors maybe that's where the because
the problem is is that we've become such
a
first world problem that we're not doing
other stuff and it takes a family but it
does help to have in my neighborhood we
had miss pivas who was like her kids
were out of the house and she would just
sit on her porch all day and judge us
right and constantly
and every time my mother bring the girl
oh by the way a little t
was not in the house by the time the
lights came on i saw him running down
the street and i'm in the car going tim
is privacy but i knew i was going to get
it that night so in that aspect you're
correct but we got to start
channeling some of this stuff by the
people who like to do karen likes to
tell on exactly so let's reward karen
yes for telling on the bad people i
can't propose to like just me barbecuing
on a friday in front of my house yeah
we're becoming a pro karen show after
knocking them
here
yeah you know i think every time i got
caught legitimately in trouble was from
a neighbor yeah like a neighbor saw me
playing hooky and neighbors saw me buy a
pack of cigarettes at the emporium when
they used to have the cigarette machines
in the stairwell cat those days
you could go in it was like
you remember those just telling on
themselves yes yeah i i don't remember
that what no they knew that the
neighbors were always the finks the
karen's and it's like if people don't do
that anymore i don't know what i'm
talking about cat do you want to take
this moment to defend facial tattoos or
would you like to offer your solution
for our problems
i mean
i like i'm not defending facial tattoos
it's neck tattoos that i'm into first of
all you never listen when i talk that's
true uh yeah i mean i think that all the
solutions that everyone's come up with
wouldn't have applied here
uh which is why i think you know there's
people who say we have to do something
we have to do something and they
criticize the thoughts and prayers
people without realizing that a lot of
them are doing the exact same thing when
they just say do something but they
don't say what or how that would help
because in illinois you know there is
the red flag law there are all of these
laws that they are presenting as
solutions and it obviously didn't change
anything it's obviously a difficult
situation but again it's
no longer a situation like you said
where we always you know say oh i never
would have guessed you know he was such
a quiet
it's people are like oh yeah no i knew
that guy was nuts it's like well then
yeah you probably should and when the
guy is trying his best to look like he's
nuts and we go well you know that's just
a choice
no he's trying to tell you because
honestly you see that guy and you're
like oh he's probably on soundcloud
because that's usually the case right
but that's a lot different than saying
i'm going to kill my whole family and
myself and talking about that all the
live long days on that point we shall
exit this segment hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else